die geschichte der menschheit muss
umgeschrieben werden ja bisher waren die
ältesten knochenfunde von menschen also
dem homo sapiens 195000 jahre alt von
sieben alter unserer spezies ging die
wissenschaft bisher aus doch nun wurden
menschliche fossilien in marokko
entdeckt die viel älter sind 300.000
jahre
was das für die forschung und unsere
art bedeutet jetzigen klick zum
seitenwechsel herzlich willkommen
eigentlich stammt die fundstelle aus den
sechziger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts doch was dort damals
gefunden wurde
darauf konnten sich die forscher keinen
reim machen die funde wurden auf ein
alter von 40.000 jahren geschätzt aber
waren so primitiv und waren eher nach
einer art neandertaler aus jacques
hublin wollte dem auf den grund gehen
doch als er sich die fundstelle marokko
in den neunzigerjahren ansah die level i
wrote höhle war das ziemlich
enttäuschend sie war komplett
verschüttet
es gab keine möglichkeit für ihn dort
zu graben mögliche funde waren viel zu
tief unter geröll vergraben übrigen
gab auf doch ganz verließ ihn nicht der
mut 2004 wurde er in die max planck
gesellschaft aufgenommen und hatte wohl
erstmal zeit und geld um an diesem ort
wieder zu graben doch erstmals musste
die höhle freigelegt werden 200
kubikmeter geröll musste sein team mit
einem bulldozer wegräumen bis der
zugang wieder frei warf und dann
gelangen den forscherinnen und forschern
dort die weiteren sensationellen fundes
immer wieder beeindruckt welche
bahnbrechenden erkenntnisse die
wissenschaft heute mit modernen methoden
erlangen kann gerade war es noch der
stammbaum der dinosaurier
wer bisher einfach falsch war und jetzt
ist es auch unsere eigene spezies die
betroffen ist fliegt sie viel länger
auf der erde wie bisher gedacht statt
rund 200.000 jahren existiert der mensch
rund 100000 jahre länger nämlich rund
300.000 jahren mindestens 187 hat sich
das thema gewünscht dass am mittwoch
für furore sorgte die funde konnten so
exakt kartiert werden weil die forscher
und forscherinnen auf eine gruppe von
fünf menschen gestoßen waren
die offenbar ihre werkzeuge engst hatten
das erlaubte dem team vom leipziger
max-planck-institut für evolutionäre
anthropologie eine weitaus genauere
datierung der kunde mittels des per mini
fans verfahren bei dem die anzahl von
elektronen gemessen wird die im laufe
der jahrtausende durch radioaktive
strahlung freigesetzt werden und sich
anhäufen und das ergebnis von 14
messung seines zweiten teams um shannon
mcpherron und daniel richter bahn
verblüffen
die funde sind 315.000 jahre alt und
damit setzt sich das puzzle der menschen
funde aus afrika ganz neu zusammen es
scheint nicht den einen ort dort als
wiege der menschheit zu geben sondern
vielmehr scheinen sich auf dem ganzen
kontinent
die verschiedenen modernen ausprägung
die gewicht gehören und so weiter des
homo sapiens entwickelt und sich dann
dort langsam über die verschiedenen
gruppen zum heutigen homo sapiens
verbunden zu haben eine lange und
komplexe entwicklung in berlin glaubt es
hat dass der mensch noch viel älter ist
er vermutet ein alter von fast einer
halben million jahre
jetzt will er in der höhle weiter
graben und hofft auf weitere
erkenntnisse wenn es dazu neues gibt
dann erfahrt ihr natürlich hier tut mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht gehen auf die glocke beim verpasst
hier garantiert kein video ansonsten
gestand blatter